kroner test sind noch immer knapp
vielleicht können dafür hunde bald
helfen das glaubt james logan er ist der
chef der krankheitskontrolle an der
universität london
wir wissen dass hunde die erstaunliche
fähigkeit haben zu riechen und gerüche
zu lernen um in kuwait 19 einen
ausgeprägten geruchssinn werden in der
lage runde darauf zu trainieren
diesen zu erkennen in großbritannien
trainiert die organisation medical
detection dogs die vierbeiner bereits
beim training müssen sie aus acht
verschiedenen gefäßen einen bestimmten
geruch riechen und anschlagen
hier hat man auch schon gute erfahrungen
mit anderen bedrohlichen krankheiten
gemacht hundetrainer ob harris berichtet
wir haben die hunde in den letzten 13
jahren für die erkennung einer reihe von
verschiedenen krankheiten ausgebildet
darunter prostatakrebs blasenkrebs
parkinson und malaria
claire guest ist gründerin von medical
detection und überzeugt hunde könnten im
medizinischen tests eine wichtige rolle
bei der eindämmung des virus spiel
sobald die hunde bei einer person
zuverlässig das corona virus anzeigen
könnten diese hunde an öffentliche orte
gehen
ein team von fünf hunden könnte
viereinhalb tausend personen pro tag
untersuchen